et cet écran d'accueil que la marque
etap table je pense toujours dès que je
le vois à cette [ __ ] chansons et je
suis un peu tape tape
si je te fais lacourte suivent mais on
attend à guaino mais la voilà qui hall
bon c'est bon c'est pas comme si on
avait été cassé en morceaux a le trait
qui revient pour de trop les honore ses
fins ça m'énerve jambes sont que le
texte là c'est un mec qui fait salut tu
veux ouvrir la porte
oh oui pourquoi pas et maman c'est fermé
attention mon ami peyratte les a pas vus
oui j'ai allaité des dépôts aussi tu as
un mec j'ai pris pas perdu
[Applaudissements]
jack jack
je crois qu'il a marché sur un cloud
mais regardez le très bien il passait
l'aspirateur avec mon corps là
who dat ass woman voici un zombie en
boîte de nuit
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression d'être surveillés
super étrange comme sensation
ah ouais tu veux faire un battle de
regards tête et des yeux avec lan party
est ce qu'on va voir ce qu'on va le voir
j'ai peur de tomber amoureux y avait pas
de gros minet j'aime gm deuxième chef
tourmenteurs tous vos déchets c'est
l'heure de la revanche a sonné ok cet
appel
ok stop à ils sont au cinéma ok les
potes même à prévenir pour le signer
qu'est-ce que quand ça se fait elle se
retourne tous saluent
ah j'aime quand tu me fais un massage
des pieds comme ça fiston oh oui j or à
huy à un peu plus comme ça je veux pour
bassin ce buzz huawei j'ai pas vu il ya
un travesti à la fenêtre en fait avec
avec une période bloquiste a par équipe
qui aime bien voir mourir et voilà c'est
lui c'est lui qui a la télécommande de
l'arbre je le vois regardez bien et
c'était vraiment pas truqués en plus et
se doit bien servir à quelque chose
cette espèce de 2min appartement là à
l'essence de la pila hobbit sauf toi
sauf toi du ko mais tu n'as qu'à man
band tout ça mais ça longtemps qu'on a
accroché un pied wifi je fais le drapeau
mais ce cheval chercheurs une position
délicate actuellement sur votre dos non
non pas les fesses pas à monsieur cheval
comment vous expliquer actuellement
c'est plutôt érotique entre nous non
j'ai atteint le million d'abonnés
ok cool j'associe ton assez doit accuser
d'en manger avec sa tête de psychopathe
r- labat et logos allez tu es prêt pour
la soie nouvel an je crois je suis
l'être non plus diabolique de la planète
à me regarder quoi ces discothèques là
dedans en fait rire dans le bloc
opératoire gdiri anormal coupé à toit
mais celle de garder leur tête là où
nous venons en paix nous aimons teibel
trompe
[Musique]
bush quoi au nom non je sors ton à la
mère basque à lui mais on va voir une
sorte de mr bean endroit le fascisme et
j'avais raison
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ça on dirait une
sorte de kebab vivant regarder j'avais
confiance en toi tu attends je croyais
et amis pour toujours aussi que cette
chose est bien une sorte d'elvis presley
avec un pot d'échappement coller à la
nuque mortels salut psychopathe ça se
passe bien dans sa tête
prend-il je tue des gens qu'elles savent
alors c'est moi ton plus beau sourire
watts est reçoit à tous c'est ce que
jean paul le respect quoi quoi
oh là bas on dire on répond oui au m 1
est ce que je peux lui dire hachad sur
what about libre tout elle c'était
justin ça ne touche pas les fesses vous
avez vraiment un pas de danse classique
quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vois a rien à manger sur le ballon tu
arrêtes non mais les mecs mais arrêtez
de vous embrasser
mais je comprends pas j'ai su qu'on
était comme un poney en attend salut moi
tu t'avances et air asia
c'est ça que tu as dit et c'est vous qui
faisait je suppose bande de potes de
bitche aaa alors casse-toi
oh la la suite incroyable dans la maison
tin tin tin tin tin tin tin tin dans le
frigo d'un frigo on peut pas aller on va
dans et pour avoir un peu de compagnie
j'en vois un bouton on est tout seul 1
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'on peut
pas faire la fête
[Musique]
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un truc dans le
coup classique 2 à o pourquoi tout ne
pouvait pas se passer juste comme ça
la famille parfaite en voiture
[Musique]
l'assocation sur son fauteuil
ok cette fois je pense qu'on va réussir
à loos watts se passe c'est quoi c'est
mon gars elle tire pas sur le site où
les mecs les compter un petit jour des
conférences
les mecs ont fait un petit peu je veux
plus aller dans la salle à manger
non non je ne t'attends pas alors ferme
d'ailleurs
salut la bayanne bougies et on a une
autre juste là bas allez on y va tous
ensemble
attention c'est bon on est à la première
bougie
et maintenant on va la deuxième trois
karaté je n'ai pas s'il veut être allons
nous en ami tu viens de battre d'accord
enfin route sans parler sans robben kaki
au l éleveur tri bouge toi le cul la
[Musique]
tête et voilà battant on obtient un b
l'arrosoir je vous mets une photo
d'arrosoir à côté voilà la ressemblance
est flagrante mais les voitures elles se
battent pas besoin de rien à [ __ ]
jabbar en retrait éventuel arrêt de
schiste m'approche ricard high five et
pourquoi ce garage et de savoie trac on
va la prendre au bahut contre x est très
utile une batterie qui attendait non w
c'est parce que vous croyez
mais c'est pas de la faute elle apparue
dans ma main
ok j'ai même pas les couilles que le
bateau soit blessé je suis tellement
bien bien sûr votre apport et prend la
tasse brindas prend la tasse boit la
tasse
montre nous ton des tons gauche
qui t'a dit j'avais un téton gauche ni
yacht ou vendre moi c'est alexandre ce
que j'ai l'air de m'appeler alexandre
j'espère que cette petite compilation de
ces six derniers mois de vidéos vous
aura plu c'est passé vite
ainsi moi dans ce que lorsque vous venez
de voir dans ce que dans ce que vous
venez à l'équipe mag ya six mois de
vidéos c'est là qu'on se dit ça passe
vite le temps merde j'ai fait ce montage
pour vous rendre heureux remercier
d'être 2 millions parce que c'est un
nombre de dengue j'avais fait ça pour
mehr millions d'abonnés j'ai vu que ça
avait pas mal plus donc je me suis dit
on pas le refaire un peut-être que ça
leur fera plaisir face à leur grand
plaisir de leur en-but en tout cas si
vous avez aimé la vidéo comme d'habitude
je vous invite à aller mais que je le
sache tout simplement encore une fois un
rebond heureux merci delà des millions
d'abonnés c'est tout simplement énorme
et on se retrouve demain dans une
nouvelle vidéo chat au monde
pis et encore
[Musique]
et